I looked myself in the mirror and I was
like what's what's your problem
oh you got to figure this out and and
really just taking that time made me
realize that all of those fears and
insecurities the causes of that anxiety
were actually very selfish because I was
thinking like well
you know I don't want to sound stupid
what if they asked me a question I don't
know the answer to and I don't want to
bother them and and the common the
common word that came up as I was going
through this was was I and me I'm like
well that's a problem
especially as as you know I I had made
this decision to to pursue this path of
service and and so that was that was
where things changed where instead of
walking into a room something that would
cause anxiety and anyone who's an
introvert and shy you can probably
relate was turned around when I realized
like stop thinking about yourself I'll
see go in this room and and take the
opportunity to connect with other people
to share Aloha with them to smile have a
nice conversation at a bare minimum